nothing spotify uh taking away comics
money that's different
yeah that's that's actually kind of
interesting story so like
spotify you're kind of on the inside of
this yeah there's a uh
so essentially what
the way that spotify and these streaming
companies pay musicians they pay the two
different royalty fees there's a
performance fee and a uh producing like
writing fee yeah right because some
people are writing their own songs and
some people aren't so like let's say for
example maroon 5 or beyonce for example
she gets a performance fee for the
streaming but there's also a team of
people that help put together that song
and they also get paid for the
production of it so spotify has to pay
those two royalties so basically uh some
people in the comedy space start saying
hey we're performing and we're writing
we want both royalties too you giving it
to these musicians why don't you give it
to us yeah and uh spotify just said
nope yup and just yanked kevin hart a
bunch of these other people out and i
think it really comes down to the fact
that like their business is not
contingent on people listening to comedy
no and not that many people are just
listening to comedy yeah um
i will say though real quick brag um
raw dog saw sirius xm and uh pandora the
station yep uh both albums that we
released this year
number one
first time they had two number one
albums so that was pretty cool thank you
guys very much you know what i mean only
getting paid one royalty you cheap [ __ ]
appreciate it uh but it is an
interesting thing especially with comedy
because
comedy is collaborative
there's so often times you'll give me a
tag i'll give you a tag right and we do
comedy together
i don't know if musicians
are collaborative without credit
like i don't know if
no everybody gets credit everybody gets
credit you put one word on the track
you're a writer you're right on the
crash so in order to do that with
royalties
oh sorry so in order to do that in
royalties for stand-up right all of a
sudden you got to talk to all your boys
that were in the green room in [ __ ]
omaha you're like yo i think you gave me
that one tag about nail clippings all
right here you go get a little piece of
strip you know what i mean and what
sorry no i'm just saying that's going to
be hard
it's a hard thing because culturally the
way comedy works is somebody could have
said something
in as reference to the joke yeah and
then you're like oh that'd be really
funny can i use that and then they're
like yeah sure use it someone in the
audience audience might change them i'll
just not say that yeah yeah
so it's almost like
as much as i want comics us to get
another royalty check and i want to be
good it will create other problems and
that's okay too we'll solve those
problems you know as we get there or we
just have to go if we put it out that's
ours and it's just all ours yeah but it
will create issues especially if you
find out [ __ ] getting crazy
checks somebody's getting ten thousand
dollars a month for a joke that you gave
a bunch of tags to helped out right
you're like yo
yup take care of your boy a little bit a
little bit tell me something
so
i don't know what do you guys think i
just don't know first of all i don't
know how much comedians make on spotify
period right like the royalties are like
0.004 cents per dollar or some [ __ ] like
that
and i also don't know uh
i lost what the [ __ ] i was going to say
they're leveraged they don't have
leverage yeah they got no leverage who
gives a [ __ ] comedy's all spotify who's
the [ __ ] the only leverage they have is
pr and i don't think people care yeah
yeah just can't use pr to get back
chappelle's show
comics aren't on spotify nobody cares
yeah yeah they're single musicians that
have more plays than all of comedy
spotify yeah and so they're like yeah
it's just not i don't think they're
looking at that as like their business
like expansion model so they're like
[ __ ] it yeah it's like we could pay out
more
for something that doesn't make us any
money
it might even in some weird convoluted
way it costs them money like just having
to keep that kind of stuff up there
updating out bandwidth exactly something
i don't know if it actually does but
like so it's just like this is already a
nuisance yeah and we're doing it just
because we want people to be able to
listen to everything yeah and now you're
gonna ask for more when you're we're
already losing on you guys now it seems
like where it could come back to bite
them is if they're trying to expand into
music and podcasting if the podcasters
happen to be comedians and then they
piss off the comics that make them not
want to do the deal yeah it could impact
them down the line but i think if they
have a big enough bag to throw it a
comedian yeah do a podcast on the
platform exclusively then they just but
if i want to throw me a hundred million
yeah [ __ ] some comments and those are
the numbers i'm sure they ran yeah
listen to me on pandora yeah i'm saying
y'all radio i'm yeah
yeah dude that's yeah i guess that is
what it is yeah i don't even think it
was them like trying a big dick i think
it was just like it's just not worth it
yeah let's take this money add a new
feature to the site make unwrapped
better yes what's going to bring us
actually you made a really good point
about unwrapped uh it's unwrapped uh the
spotify at the end of the year all the
[ __ ] you listen to you want to share
that i mean this is like a tweet that
people have been passing around but
basically like spotify and rapt is like
how they make your data
how you how you they make it cool for
people to use your data
like everybody's sharing the fact that
spotify mined their data all year and
listened to every single thing and
watched observed yeah every single thing
they did on the platform and they
packaged it in a way that was cool
enough where we want to share it yeah
like this is this is this is all the
information i gave this company yeah so
they could use to everyone more people
like me yeah every platform needs to do
it unwrapped yeah because then it makes
it like oh yeah we can all know that
you're taking our data but at least make
it fun for us